من فرنسا بعد خساره فرنسا نهائي كاس
العالم تحولت الخساره الى اعصار في المشهد
الكروي بطلوا هذا الاعصار زين الدين زيدان
اطلقه رئيس اتحاد كره القدم الفرنسيه نويل
غريت خلال لقائه مع راديو مونت كارلو بعد
الاتفاق على التمديد التعاقد مع مدرب
المنتخب
2026 سيلون من الاعتراضات والهجوم قبل
تصريحات من ريال مدريد الذي عاش افضل
فتراته تحت اداره الديدان وحتى وزيره
الرياضه الفرنسيه وسط اصوات المتعاليات
تطالب بتنحيه زيدان الذي حقق كل شيء لاعبا
ومدربا لم يعلق لكن رئيس الاتحاد واعتذر
وقال ان تصريحات لا تعبر تماما عن وجهه
نظره واقر بانها
لنكن صريحي هذا البلد فرنسا لم يكن
تاريخيا بين الكبار في عالم كره القدم
وحتى الان لم يحقق اي بلد انجازات كرويه
مثل فرنسا اربعه نهائيات في المونديال
وكاسان وهناك رمز كبير لهذا التحول واسمه
زين الدين زيدان
[موسيقى]
كان فيها يغلط
ويسيل
انا قلبك صليبه
[موسيقى]
اخر ثاني والليله
عام
1998 عندما ربحت فرنسا كاس العالم بقياده
زين الدين
2018 2016
ترجمه
[موسيقى]
رئيس الاتحاد الفرنسي لكره القدم
اتى من النجم الجديد الذي قال زيدان هو
فرنسا يجب ان لا نقلل من احترامه الاسطوره
بعد كل السنوات
وسيذكر الجميع هذا التصريح للمدير السابق
لمانشستر يونايتد سر اعطيني
جديده وعشروا قطعا من الخشب وسافوز بدوري
الابطال ايت مزاري باريس
1994 يشارك زين الدين زيدان ابن الثانيه
والعشرين المره الاولى مع منتخب فرنسا في
الشوط الثاني امام تشيك يسجل هدفه الاول
بعد دقيقه ولا يحتفل حيث لا يزال الديوك
مطالبين بهدف اخر لمعادله النتيجه بعد
دقيقتين فقط يتلقى الشاب الصغير زيدان
عرضيه ويضربها براسه في الزاويه العليا
لتسكن الشباك هنا يدرك الجمهور ان هناك
شيئا استثنائيا يحدث امام اعينهم
الى دلوقتي مستوى عندما استضافه فرنسا
مونديال عام
1998 وبعد عامين يفوز بافضل لاعب في امم
اوروبا 2000 بعد احراز بلاده لقب في 2006
يعيش زيدان رائع لكنه يخسر النهائي الا ان
اخوي يتصدر لعناوين وذلك بعض نطقته
الشهيره للمدافع متراتي صانع الالعاب
الساحر يعتزل كره القدم بعد عقد من الزمان
يتولى زمام الامور في مدريد يتوج باحد عشر
لقبا ويثبت انه ضمن الافضل لاعبا ومدربا
ينضم الينا من باريس المزيد من التفاصيل
مراسل صباح العربيه ليت بازاري يسعد صباحك
يا ليث اهلا بك يعني اسطوره قدم كره القدم
الفرنسيه وصوره كره القدم الرياضيه يتعرض
لتصريحات غير لائقه من رئيس الاتحاد
الفرنسي لكره القدم تفاصيل ليث معك ما
الذي تحمله يا ليث
قبل ما نحكي على اللي حامله سهام رغم
السلبيه
صح من المونديال نعم نعم في في ايجابيه
بالموضوع في شويه ايجابيه لبدايه هذا
العام
وتعود قصه فطيره الملوك اذا ترجمت عربيا
لعهد الرومان القدماء حيث تكون هذه
المناسبه 12 يوم بعد عيد الميلاد الذي
يكون طبعا في الخامس والعشرين من ديسمبر
عند طهيها توضع عليها او في داخلها حبه
فاصوليا او حبه او فول من البلاستيك او
المعاصر منها دميه صغيره على شكل ملك ومن
تكون من نصيبه يرتدي التاج الذي يقدم مع
الفطيره عند شرائها اشاره تطلع عندنا بس
تفتحها بعد شويه
الوحيد الذي تقدم
نعم نعم نعم نعم على ههه على كل حال
المكان الوحيد الذي لا تقدم فيه فطيره
الملوك هو قصر الاليزيه قصر الرئيس لانه
بكل بساطه وقصر جمهوري وليس قصر ملكي
والفطيره هذه من صنع طاعه طبعا
في باريس وتحمل اسم لاغو الملوك تنتظرنا
وهي مكونه من كريم اللوز بنكهه زهره
البرتقال كغمليزيه المكرمه اذا ترجمناه
بالعربي والجزء العلوي منها مغطى بطبقه
رقيقه من الفطر همم
الخفيف ومرشوش عليها همم رذاذ من السكر
الذي يبدو وكانه النجوم تتلالا اذا شفنا
هيك قربنا
موسمها على كل حال فرنسا مشهوره بالحلويات
على طول في مواسم مختلفه بكل فصل في مو-
نوع معين من الحلويات التي تقدم او تصنع
في فرنسا الازمات الرياضيه لم تبدا اليوم
يعني اذا حكينا نرجع لزيدان فهي مندلعه
قبل كاس العالم في قطر اذ تم ابعاد كريم
بنزيما كذلك من قبل مدرب المنتخب الفرنسي
بسبب اصابته بالرغم ان الاعياد الاسبانيه
التي كان يعالج فيها اطلق صراحه وكان
بامكانه اللاعب في مباريات كاس العالم
باريس
صحيح صحيح
المنتخب الفرنسي سهام الى باريس بعد عودته
من قطر وتصنيفه الثاني او الوسيط لبطل
العالم همم الارجنتين رفض الاتحاد الفرنسي
لكره القدم مره اخرى للقيام باحتفال
لاستقبال المنتخب ولكن رغم انف ادارته
المدرب دي شو هو لاعبيه باقامه حفل من على
شرفه فندق خريون في ساحه الذي يطل على
ساحه الكونكورد الفرنسيه بحضور الاف
المشجعين والمعجبين يعني بنحس انه في هناك
توتر بين ان كان همم اعضاء المنتخب
الفرنسي او لاعبي المنتخب الفرنسي
والاداره الاتحاد الكره والفرنسي يعني اذا
برده شاهدنا ماننسا لما كنا بقطر من غلق
الموضوع ما بنسى مبابي مع اشرف حكيمي وكيف
تبادل القمصان همم عندما لعبت فرنسا او
فازت على المنتخب المغربي وهذه بيبين انه
برده في اشياء يعني تكون عاده اللاعب همم
يكون همم هالايام اللاعب اهم من اداره
الانديه او اداره الاتحاد الكروي لكره
القدم على الاقل في فرنسا شكرا جزيلا لك
من باريس مراسل صباح العربيه ليست ما زال
شكرا